c'est un autre magnifique cartographie
du ciel en trois dimensions que nous on
a fait récemment le télescope spatial
européen
gaia un véritable ballet celui de 14 mai
l'astéroïde qui circulent autour du
soleil et dont on peut maintenant suivre
les orbites individuellement et c'est
loin d'être le premier fait d'armes de
cet instrument scientifique hors du
commun
c'est un satellite à quai dans l'espace
et qui a pour mission de cartographier
en fait une grande fraction de la
galaxie c'est à dire de déterminer la
position et la vitesse de plus de 1
milliard des toiles dans les galaxies
les lancer en 2013
gaia est équipé de deux miroirs de très
grande précision qui observent le ciel à
360° et peuvent produire des images
d'une résolution 2 milliards de pixels
en plus d'avoir catalogué des centaines
de millions de nouvelles étoiles le
téléscope fourni sur chacune d'elles des
données sur la distance qui les sépare
de la terre la distance des objets dans
dans l'univers c'est une quantité
fondamental qu'on en connaît d'autres
par exemple la luminosité intrinsèque
quelle est la masse quelle est leur
rayon de 2 de l'étoile et jusqu'à
présent on peut seulement les déduire de
manière indirecte ou essayer de le
domaine de musri comme gaye apple femme
avec une position beaucoup plus ferme
gaye a déjà révélé cette spectaculaire
animations à trois dimensions de la voie
lactée où l'on anticipe le déplacement
des étoiles sur plusieurs millions
d'années
ou encore cette carte qui permet de
traverser virtuellement notre galaxie
mais si les données de gaia vont encore
alimenter les chercheurs pendant
plusieurs années la vie utile du
télescope européen tire à sa fin
et bientôt c'est le grand télescope
américain james webb qui prendra sa
relève
ces missions absolument qui va
révolutionner la strada son physique
dans tous les domaines que ce soit pour
comprendre les premières galaxies se
sont allumés ou débuts du big bang
jusqu'à sonder l'atmosphère des open up
savoir si le lot du méthane mission de
10 milliards de dollars dont un au
canada et un état partenaire donc ces
machines prenons la plus complexe en
cours de construction par l'humanité en
principe le télescope james webb devrait
être lancé par la nasa
au printemps 2000 21 ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal